thanks everybody for coming to our talk
uh the talk is titled tech when the sky
is following tools for crisis response
a little bit about us my name is colin
schimmelthing
i am currently doing a masters of
environmental science and management at
uc santa barbara's brend school for the
environment or as i like to call it an
mba for hippies
i've also spent before this 10 years as
a software engineer and engineering
manager
and i'm emma ferguson
i'm currently a full stack and
infrastructure engineer at samsara which
is an iot operations company i make
technology for trucks and i've been a
software engineer for about five years
before that i was a data analyst for
some years
cool and we actually we know each other
from college so we've known each other
for over a decade and this is the first
time that we've actually worked together
on the same project
so let's introduce the most important
character in this talk mask match mask
match is a peer-to-peer mask donation
website that we ran from march to july
of 2020.
it enabled donations of masks from
individuals directly to health care
providers and workers
in order to ease the personal protective
equipment shortage that was like so
rampant around the world in early 2020
and we delivered almost a million masks
so this talk is going to be about how we
got there and what you can learn from
our terrible mistakes
so
we're trying to give you in this talk a
framework for tech enabled crisis
response that sounds like a lot of words
we'll break it down
but basically
we don't think that covet is the last
global crisis that we will experience in
our lifetime and and your lifetimes and
given that you are sitting in this room
you will probably want to help and you
probably have the tech skills that you
might want to use to try and help so we
would love to give you a little bit of
an idea of what you might expect so that
you can hit the ground running and help
the most effective way possible
here's our framework that we kind of
came up with thinking about the
different phases of what one of these
tech enabled crisis responses what they
look like
so five different phases will break down
each one but phase one validate your
idea make it repeatable scale vertically
stabilize and then adapt or shut down
before we jump into mass match um we
want to say a little bit about what
we're not going to talk about in this
talk um mass match was not a long-term
non-profit that we built to like
continue on into the future past us it
was crisis response what that means is
it was not a sustainable effort crises
are short-term
a crisis is going to require immediate
intervention and so when you are working
on crisis response your measures will be
stop gap a crisis is very specific and
your crisis response is not going to
change an entire system and finally a
crisis does not occur in a vacuum and so
crisis response should be as equitable
as possible within the time constraints
that you're working within
okay
so let's get into this
remember back in march 2020 where were
you just think about that and think
about how you felt at the time
at the time
covet had gone from something that was
really scary happening in china and
italy to now something that was here in
the united states cases were exploding
everybody was trying to figure out well
how does it spread what do we do
nobody had any idea
everybody was trying to lock down bend
the curve it was all scary
and there was one sort of sub crisis
that was coming to really dominate the
news which was the personal protective
equipment shortage for healthcare
workers um the situation we were in was
we are facing a like national and indeed
global healthcare crisis and we have no
way to protect the healthcare workers
who could be keeping the rest of us safe
um the world health organizat
organization is like putting out these
bulletins that are like so apocalyptic
um and it was like everywhere um for
those of us sitting at home and just
like refreshing our news apps it was
like felt like this was the only thing
there and it also felt like we couldn't
do anything about it all we could do is
just sit there the best thing we could
do is stay home and that felt powerless
so
when this email
ended up in my inbox
i was intrigued
emma could you actually fill me in
i knew almost nothing
elena is a mutual friend of ours who we
also went to college with uh and she had
some call in this email um that she had
hooked him up with me previously she had
sent me a mystery zoom link to talk to
these two women about something um so
about 30 minutes after colin got this
email we got onto a zoom call with these
two women um liz klinger and chloe
alpert are both co-founders and ceos of
startups in the healthcare space
additionally liz's mom was a nurse so
she was getting this very up close and
personal view of the ppe shortage
so we got on this zoom call with them to
talk about some kind of coveted response
project
they had this very elegant idea
so
the idea was healthcare workers need
masks and lots of people have mass at
home whether that's in california
because of wildfires or just under their
work bench for when they're sanding or
painting something
however if those people tried to donate
those masks to healthcare workers
especially at hospitals the hospital
administrators would just throw away
those masks which was a complete tragedy
they wouldn't accept it for liability
reasons however
if you were a nurse or doctor or
healthcare worker you could bring your
own ppe in and share it with your
colleagues so
that leads to the following idea what's
skip the hospitals and mail masks from
people who have them directly to
healthcare workers that was their idea
and they had set up a very simple
website about 24 hours prior i just
started recording a bunch of stuff in
google sheets
and they had within 24 hours 300
requests for masks from healthcare
workers and a few donations mostly from
their friends
so we're going to show you
while they were telling telling us this
and we were thinking about well should
we do it or not uh we were texting each
other back and forth and we'll show you
a little bit behind the scenes what what
we were doing
so classic software engineers so we have
a cool project right
we were like this will probably take
like a weekend right like classic time
estimation yeah that's not our strong
suit yeah
it turned out it was a little more
complicated than that but we got on the
zoom call we said yes sounds great and
that dropped us into phase one
phase one is validate your solution you
see a problem you have an idea figure
out if it actually helps this took from
mass match about 36 hours
so
the problem statement for your phase one
is going to be does your plan solution
solve the problem you've identified
your planning horizon is right now you
are not doing any future planning it is
only about what is breaking in this
moment and your technical priorities are
create some kind of process reduce
errors with that process and then track
your successes so you can tell if it's
working
so here is the process that we came up
with
one validation we wanted to make sure
that the people sending us requests for
masks were actually frontline healthcare
workers so we did some lightweight
validation mostly using linkedin
two make matches so you have people
saying i have masks you have people
saying i need masks you match them up
you ask the donors to send you send the
donor the recipient's
home address and then you ask the donor
to send you back a tracking number and
then there are follow-up communications
once you get that tracking number back
you email it to the person who's going
to be getting the mask so they know when
the package is going to arrive
there's also
some like bookkeeping so you mark that
match as complete so you're not trying
to like send the same person to the same
two people the same masks
and then there's a lot of tracking down
donations so you email your donors these
recipient addresses you never get
tracking numbers and you spend a lot of
time getting like hey
friend did you put those masks in the
mail and this is all happening in this
system
so we have a website really simple
squarespace type form forms that flow
into google sheets and then all the
volunteer jobs i just outlined are
basically in gmail inboxes and then
going back and forth with those google
sheets and if you ever built a little
web app you're going to notice that our
data flow is a little messy and a lot of
the problems are going to occur pretty
much right about here
so in these first 36 hours
all we were trying to do is like take uh
total disaster google sheets and turn
them into human readable google sheets
uh things like instead of five or six
colors of green highlighting maybe use
different colors so you can tell what
the colors mean when you look at the
sheet um maybe like try to get the type
form form such that the address data is
always coming in in the same format
really really basic um this is
incredibly tech lite and this is not
actually software engineering you might
notice all you're trying to do in this
phase is figure out does it work and
then set your operations up so that
you're enabling tech in your next phases
so
at the end of this phase all we had
learned was okay this totally works in
the first 36 hours we shipped about 300
mass to healthcare workers
not a lot but enough to tell us that
this can this can work
so phase two is now make it repeatable
you know that you can do
the operation of getting masks from
people who have them to health care
workers let's actually start to use
software to really make this this happen
for us this took two days probably this
will take longer that was a very
short two days
um so it's working great we're getting
mass to health care workers we're
getting press we're getting donations uh
we go from four volunteers to 39
volunteers to 73 volunteers one day
later which is awesome but then chaos so
now we have 73 volunteers and they are
working out of two tabs of a giant
google sheet guess how many concurrent
edits you can have on a google sheet yes
that's 50 which is less than 73 you're
all good at math
that was chaos then working out of three
gmail inboxes guess how many emails you
can send from one gmail inbox every day
that's 500 emails per day but we're
sending three per donation and so our
volunteers are literally having to
choose between waiting until the next
day to email somebody or emailing
somebody from a different email address
than they've already been communicating
with because that email address is out
of emails for that day so it was chaos
it was stressful it was not great and we
were having some data integrity
issues as well where
maybe somebody has double allocated a
donation somebody's promised 10 masks
and then somebody else has promised the
same temnasts and now you have to go and
really
hustle to try and find those other 10
masks
or just unclear statuses and comments so
when you're trying to deal with these
issues
how do you do that
that's right more email which just goes
right back to the first problem and
sets you right back into email hell
again
so the problem here is how do you use
technology to repeatedly successfully
apply your solution
and the planning horizon is right now
you are just getting slammed with issues
left and right everything's on fire your
technical priorities are trying to lock
down that data data integrity enable
volunteer workflows to actually work and
then measure your impact
for data integrity google sheets is
probably still the right tool at this
point but let's just lock it down a
little bit log at us to certain fields
conditional formatting
have sort of enum fields
so it's just a drop down instead of
completed done sent all those things
meaning maybe the same thing maybe
different things just have one
let's talk a little bit about data
integrity it's going to show up again
later in this talk
that incorrect or misleading data causes
the operational chaos that we were just
talking about it also gives you a really
poor foundation for future tools because
you can't trust what your tools are
reading from and writing to you
and it also causes friction
spoiler alert we eventually moved to
postgres and when we did we had to spend
three weeks cleaning data from this
part of the process so investing in data
quality always has guaranteed returns in
our experience and we wish we had done
more of that earlier
so
enable volunteer tasks is the next piece
of this phase our inboxes were a train
wreck as as we discussed so let's build
an email tool to take some of those
emails out of gmail open up those emails
for actual communication with uh
individuals instead of the initial
matching emails
so
we built a flask app hosted on heroku
very simple sent emails via mail gun
there's a basic ui that the volunteers
could do to kind of customize that that
email
but it took a lot of the legwork out of
our volunteer time and and kept it uh
very simple for folks
it was integrated with google sheets so
as they were working on a donation there
would be a link pre-populated they could
click on and it would just open up this
flask app
with everything pre-populated and no
more copy pasting for our volunteers
and we also realized okay how can we
take things out of google sheets well
verifying is a healthcare worker
actually a healthcare worker was kind of
a self-contained task so
let's
try and make something make a tool for
that but we didn't want to build and
maintain a web app just for that we
didn't want to have to figure out how to
deploy it having version controls all
that kind of stuff
and luckily a
one of our tech volunteers knew about
something called retool
there's a lot of solutions like this
it's a low code solution
that allows you to build workflows and
you kind of drag and drop ui elements to
create a
basically a mini web app for our users
um we'll talk a little bit more about it
in the future but this was a lifesaver
and they were super generous both with
free retool and their time so big shout
out to these guys
lastly measure impact uh you need to
know are you actually shipping are you
actually doing something useful
luckily since we're in google sheets you
just open up another tab point to the
other tabs and make pretty graphs
so here's where the system looks like
after phase two
and things are going well we have
shipped sixteen hundred mass after four
days
so
now that things are a little more
acceptably working
it's time to scale your impact so this
is when you hit phase three after you've
kind of found that product market fit
and after you have a solution that
actually you can do repeatably
uh out there in the world uh covet and
the ppe shortage hadn't changed that
much again it had actually only been
four days even though it felt like weeks
so these very acute ppe shortages are
still getting much worse
for us the four days had been truly
insane for us on the tech side but also
on the more operational side liz one of
our co-founders had gone out and started
getting press from npr abc news fox news
some local san francisco news and we
were getting way more donations and
volunteers which enabled us to scale
so the question here becomes how can you
increase your impact as much as possible
and this has become sort of like a
classic software engineering scaling
thing
so your planning horizon is now a
luxurious approximately three days
you can take exactly one very deep
breath and then get back to work and
your technical priorities are one to
increase your volunteer efficiency which
probably means it's time for better
internal tools and you probably at this
point should make a real database
so
volunteer tooling breakdowns let us say
once again that google sheets in our
shared inboxes were not working that
well right now uh the rate limiting for
email sends is killing us and at this
point there were so many people trying
to use our sheet that most of the time
the page literally did not load um so we
were like let's just pay google for
stuff um we can probably pay for more
email sends we can probably pay to get
better access to google sheets and we
tried we really tried we tried to pay
google and we could not figure out how
to pay google for these things um and so
instead we decided to build it ourselves
um
so to start with we were like we have
got to fix the email thing um we
realized that what we were asking our
volunteers to do was basically a support
flow right so it's like support tickets
you're getting emails from people you
need to respond to them with information
um we asked a volunteer to go out and
find us something like could we use
zendesk help us figure it out and they
found free scout which is an open source
self-hosted zendesk alternative it's
really similar to zendesk really similar
to help scout and it was very very easy
to set up and get working it had a lot
of functionality we needed people could
assign cases to themselves there were
like email templates and all that good
stuff
and it was a real life saver we used it
for the rest of the project
we also realized using the shiny google
sheets analytics we implemented in the
previous phase that volunteers were
spending a lot of time making matches
but then some of those matches were
never getting completed we had a status
where we'd like say like okay this
donation is matched and then it would
just sit there um and we figured that
this was probably happening because
people were just never opening the
emails from us
um so we added a twilio integration to
that original little heroku email app so
that a volunteer could with one click
also send a text message um the text
message i think originally just said
please check your email mask match um
and it really helped
yeah it worked um it helped us move a
lot of those like you know sitting
around donations into a completed phase
all right next data integrity again um
so we had locked down the google sheet a
lot but again now the page wasn't
loading um it was awful uh so we were
like we have to just move everyone out
of google sheets so we built a lot more
retool tools we went from one retail
tool for just that validation process to
retool tools for pretty much everything
this was amazing because we could back
it by google sheets and then when we
were ready to switch to postgres which
we will see in one moment we could just
switch over the back ends um made it
super easy to go through that transition
for our volunteers
and finally it's time for a real
database
we did pick postgres
it was easy we ran on aws it was great
it solved a lot of problems for us first
of all postgres has way better i o
scalability characteristics than google
sheets um so that was a big upgrade for
us a big thing was security this meant
fewer volunteers only our tech team had
direct access to our data again at this
point we've got like 200 something
volunteers and so that was becoming a
big concern
data hygiene postgres has some nice
normal stuff like foreign keys and
constraints it was like a dream
and finally stability uh this was
actually the most important thing uh
moving over to postgres unlocked for us
a whole world of potential automations
um which we'll get into in the next
phase
so uh by the end of phase three um we
basically moved to some actual software
um it was really exciting uh and by the
end of the phase uh the scaling was
starting to take off so like we sent
1600 mass in the first four days about
two weeks later we sent 93 000 masks um
so the scaling was like having the
intended effect
cool
so
we were scaling uh
phase four is called stabilize i think
you'll see why in a minute um at this
point it's april 10th we're a month in
and this phase took us about a month
so
in the world
the covid curve has started to flatten
but there's still a huge need for ppe at
this point
however
our team is burning out our tech team is
burning out some of our volunteers are
burning out
so we realized well actually let's focus
a little bit on how do we maintain our
impact but still ensure a stable
organization
this you have a planning horizon here of
maybe two to three weeks and your
technical priorities are to harden your
tooling try and introduce automation and
then better metrics
so
hardening the tools
constant tooling changes as emma was
just describing we changed basically
everything that our volunteers were
doing in a very short span and a lot of
volunteers burned out from that nobody
likes coming in thinking that they're
going to be able to help out and having
to relearn everything every single time
and
there were also a lot of bugs introduced
from all of our code that we had just
written
so
that was also very demoralizing for our
volunteers
let's improve the ux and improve the
documentation for those users um let's
start working inside of retool there you
can put javascript in there um and and
really uh
take that to the next level
um and also try and fix some of the bugs
we love retool but it doesn't use
database transactions
really well we had to sort of hack it to
make that happen and that was super
important to
actually leverage this amazing database
that we had now instead of google sheets
we also then were able to do automation
so some folks on our team made it an
auto matcher that automatically handled
that initial find somebody who has masks
find somebody who needs masks make sure
they're close together
and say this is a good match it was a
bin packing algorithm it worked on aws
as a worker running on aws
made possible by that postgres database
and in retool there was an interface for
a volunteer to just go yep that was good
let's let's send the emails
finally better metrics
i don't know if you noticed in the tech
stack from last time but our tech stack
actually took a step back in terms of
analytics
we never we didn't have those nice
graphs anymore instead it was emma and
myself writing running sql queries
against the database and that got old
really fast so we decided okay let's try
and do a business intelligence tool
maybe that's
tableau or domo or whatever we ended up
going with metabase it's open source
it could be really easily deployed on
aws via docker it we just spun it up
pointed it
at the database and it was perfect so
highly recommend that
here's where we are at the end of our
stabilization
period so a few more retool tools the
auto matcher and then metabase and at
this point all that scaling work that we
had done in
uh phase three had really started to
continue to
to work and so we were up over half a
million masks at this point
okay
so uh we were in a pretty steady state
at this point uh within mass match but
around us the world was changing
so the crisis really like took a turn
here um the requests that we were
getting from healthcare workers started
to really taper off which was awesome
because that meant that healthcare
workers were able to get masks and ppe
from their employers now instead of
needing to get it donated um in the us
at that time also we were starting to
face another coveted wave
and we were concerned that we were going
to get into this place where if the ppe
shortage occurred we weren't going to
have the same number of donations um
again we were just asking people to like
go into their closets and get whatever
spare masks they had and at some point
it's like that supply is over right like
it's not like an endless number of n95s
sitting in people's tool sheds um so we
wanted to make sure that we didn't get
into a place where we were promising
help when we couldn't deliver
so in phase five um your problems are no
longer technical they are purely
existential should you chase a new
crisis with what you've built or should
you shut down
um the planning horizon is like one
month ish but really it's like however
long it takes you to figure this out
and you do have technical priorities
here number one is to keep delivering
impact because you can keep helping out
even while you're making these heady
decisions
and also evaluate your system to try to
figure out what your options are as an
organization
in terms of continuing to deliver impact
one thing that we definitely encountered
in this phase is as the crisis kind of
the ppe crisis specifically came out of
the news
we weren't getting as many new
volunteers in to replace volunteers who
might have been burning out and so we
didn't make many tech changes but we did
make tweaks to increase volunteer
efficiency and the auto matter that we
had deployed in the last phase like
really saved our bacon here
and we delivered almost half of our mass
volume in this phase even with a much
reduced volunteer force
next adapt the world around you um we
don't have we can't tell you exactly
what your crisis is going to be like but
here are some of the framing questions
that we use to determine like what our
next steps should be
first does your crisis still exist for
us the answer was not really uh the ppe
supply chains around the world had
normalized so much um that we weren't
providing that much value to healthcare
workers anymore
next is your solution still the most
effective um so
despite the fact that we were not
getting that many donations anymore the
donations we were getting were suddenly
much larger so people are writing in
saying like i have a hundred thousand
masks and i want you to distribute them
um we did handle some of those donations
but our system was really set up for
those much smaller donations that you
could just send to someone's house it's
really hard to send a hundred thousand
masks to like some doctor's house and
ask them to bring them into the hospital
for you um there was another
organization called get us ppe that had
been trying to coordinate much larger
donations from much earlier and so for
us there was an easy option to redirect
those large donors to someone else whose
solutions was better built for that
situation
next can your technical system solve a
different problem is there something
else we could be donating from people's
work benches and their closets to
healthcare workers into someone else our
system was so purpose-built for masks it
just did not make sense for us to try to
do that
but
maybe you'll be in a different situation
maybe your tech will be way cleaner than
ours
and finally how burnt out are you how
burnt out is your team um we were
extremely burnt out we had basically
been running mass match as a second
full-time job at this point for almost
three months um again we really thought
this was going to be like a fun single
weekend project
and we did not have the bandwidth to try
to pivot this to address a different
crisis
so that left us with the option to
gracefully shut down um
we don't have anything groundbreaking to
say about this the only thing we want to
emphasize here is it's important to
communicate clearly with your volunteers
if you have volunteers um they've been
kind of keeping you running for months
and you don't want to hear about this
them to hear about this from like your
tweet or your blog post um send nice
emails text your favorite volunteers
it's just polite
and then go through normal text shutdown
stuff so restrict access to your tools
and your data as early as possible
export your database don't leave your
database like hanging out there on aws
for hackers to find and shut your tools
down and then finally uh write a tech
conference talk to share what you
learned with the check
so here's our final project status um we
sent
not quite a million masks
we sent them to about six thousand
health care workers all around the
united states we built an entire
startup's worth of tools in about four
weeks
this is our final tech stack it is total
skunk works it was a frankenstein tech
stack but it did the job um it got us to
where we needed to go and at every stage
it enabled us to like move forward and
keep making progress and keep having
impact
great so
we want to look back and recap some of
the lessons that we hope you can take
away from this
in this framework
when you are
yourself trying to respond to a crisis
with technology try and think about
which one of these phases are you in and
what what problem are you trying to
solve so are you trying to validate your
idea are you trying to make it
repeatable are you trying to vertically
scale it
are you trying to stabilize it
or are you in the process of needing to
figure out should you adapt or should
you shut down our real hope for this is
that um not that you're going to go
through these exact stages as we did um
but we hope that by having some context
about what this could be like for you um
you feel a little more confident about
like saying yes um if someone comes to
you with an idea and you don't know if
it's a good idea but there's a crisis
out there and maybe your tech skills
could help um remember
there is there is a plan you can follow
our plan uh it's worth saying yes and
and trying
and of course we need to thank everyone
on this slide but especially liz klinger
our ceo and fearless leader uh
you can't build tools for nobody so
obviously our volunteers who actually
did all the work of mass match and then
of course our volunteers can't send mass
if there aren't masks to send so the
seven thousand masked donors who uh
reached into their closets to help out
with that
thank you
okay so the question was uh what did we
have this framework at the time or did
we come up with it retrospectively and
what were the what were the resources at
the time
uh we did not have this at the time
yeah this is all retrospective um i
don't think i mean we don't have like an
appendix slide with great resources a
book that i desperately that i read
sense that i desperately wish i had read
before is a book called uh mutual aid by
dean spade um if you are interested in
crisis response cannot recommend it
enough um it touches on a lot of the
operational and equity pieces that we
did not have time to get into in this
talk um but we would love to talk about
at any point as well we could write an
entire talk just on that we also were
the sort of coo
role for this organization as well
managing all the volunteers
yeah the question is like how do you
practice for a situation like this um
we had done a hackathon together
previously it was not good practice for
this um i think um
part of the difficulty of this and the
reason that our framework is a little
vague is that it's gonna be very
purpose-built around the problem you're
trying to solve
i don't know that
i i mean i think that
maybe doing something like setting up a
conference would help out with that um
so
or i don't know also if you can work on
internal tools within your organization
i came from a background of doing
internal tools so i was familiar with bi
tools and you know ritual had come
across at some point as well
that's a way of doing it it might be a
too big of a change but maybe doing
something like a conference or trying to
set up those um clicking those systems
together
could do that
yeah
but also you'll figure it out uh you
know as long as you have as long as you
have a good tech team like it's a bunch
of people smart people in a room
together like really motivated you will
you'll be fine
so the question is were there any
security concerns
and how do we handle those especially
around emails
certainly oh god there were so many
security concerns um we we tried to
mitigate it as best we did as best we
could um a lot of our negations were
very operational so um it was like we
locked down like no one could export the
whole google sheet for example we did a
lot of like permissioning stuff we also
had like a volunteer code of conduct
that's spelled out really specifically
um you will never export any data
outside of our systems and you will not
contact people except like you know oh i
just want to talk to this person no yeah
yeah so there was the policy and then
there was pulling it out of google
sheets as soon as we could as well i
think into retool yeah and yeah moving
to retail but also the move to postgres
was definitely like something like that
was part of our concern was like okay we
have so many volunteers now we are not
personally we have volunteer captains
we're on boarding people but we're no
longer personally vetting volunteers um
yeah i wish i had like a great answer
about like we did these smart things for
security um but i think at the time we
were like we just want to trust that our
volunteers are here to help um and we're
going to make a code of conduct that
allows us to eject people who abuse
anything
yeah
so the question is did we have to deal
with abusers and trolls
there were a couple people who said oh
i'm a health care worker i need 10 000
masks and they were usually pretty easy
to spot
it's possible that some people got
through but that's why we started uh
really verifying people pretty closely
and we
we've revamped that and made it a little
harder um to prove that you were a
healthcare worker um
a couple of days into it yeah also most
people who were in were saying like i
need 50 masks um i think just the scale
of donations we were providing was not
enough for us to be a target and anyone
who said like i need ten thousand mask
you're automatically like
um i think on the flip side in our
volunteer community um we did not have a
problem with
like within the community people being
horrible to each other which is really
lucky we also said like no volunteers
who are like we got a bunch of emails
from people who are like high schoolers
who are doing like you know school from
home and we're like i want to help out
and we said no one under 18. um we also
said like no volunteers who don't
already know how to use google sheets
and slack and so that mostly meant we
were getting people who were like
professional age and who were used to
like working together with other people
in a virtual space and so that i think
just like made it a little easier for us
yeah cool okay maybe one more question
and then we'll let you all go to lunch
yeah
yeah the question is like some of our
stuff is not free how do we pay for it
uh which is a great question um we did
get donations um we asked for we like
set up a gofundme to get like three
thousand dollars to pay for like that'll
basically fund us forever and then we
got way more money um a great thing i
mean
this is a horrible thing to say in a
crisis situation people want to help and
giving you money is a really easy way
for people to help and so um some of the
things like you know we implemented free
scout which was free and it was great if
we had just paid for zendesk would that
have saved us any time um you're gonna
get money from people like most likely
and again like you're not trying to run
this forever so even if you are like
if we had paid all our twilio costs out
of pocket i think we would have spent
like
345 dollars um so
it's just not an it's it's not
largely enough money that you couldn't
just pay for stuff to make your life
easier and in fact i think we wish we
had just paid for more stuff to make our
lives easier or just asked for more free
stuff so retool gave us free stuff y
combinator the accelerator in san
francisco they just said here's ten
thousand dollars go spend it on aws
whatever you want so postgres like was
running on a server that was paid by
them um i think squarespace gave us that
right give us our website for free so
everyone was super generous at the time
um and and we appreciate that yeah
cool well thank you for coming to our
talk and uh
[Music]
you